this is incredible no one's ever done
anything for 24 hours in human history
it's true this is a whole new level we
are there's a lot actually very popular
genre oh really is that a man oh I
thought we were like the first people
yeah not even close
so he's got a 2009 you can probably get
on the ground floor or something so we
did this off I was pretty sure that this
was smashing through a whole new reality
I didn't realize that has anyone okay
it's tapped into reality I would say
smash we've definitely broken through
some kind of crazy I drank so much
coffee I've had drank I've had I don't
think I have drunken I have done drunken
I had that me no it is it's me done
drunk and coffee much me done drinking
coffee much yeah yeah me done drunk and
coffee I'm eating I'm drunk I got my
hairdo and look at that yeah I think I
do I hate to do this to you kind of I
think people would love to vision to
touch your hair again because what they
weren't here the very beginning this
stream I think it'd be great
grab that virtually guys get all the way
up to the screen this you turn this into
a ton traffic it's a music wave I know
this is what they're gonna do you say
that what you're gonna do you're gonna
give them ideas what I know you could
put in here and then my head no yes why
I thought of and what I went home and
did so I could watch myself this is
definitely the end of a 24 hours dream
for sure 100% we did it you know there's
a lot of people that said there's no way
you could pull this off and then there's
a lot yeah then there's a lot of other
people that said what do you mean it's
quite common on the show today
you know I'm really glad you asked
because I don't know we've had a good
show man did you check out our Monday
show Oh incredible tell him that was so
good wait our Monday
this past Monday that somebody the show
that we did yes that this hour we had it
was great to me
yeah Kevin Hart was about to say you
would not pass a sobriety test right
Kevin on the show that was on the show
and it was one of my favorite that's
right he's always funny but I think was
my favorite Kevin Hart appearances he's
amazing you talked all about his Super
Bowl yeah
sumo wrestling we did for Kevin show
that's right that's gonna be coming out
I think any day now that's right yeah
what's that next week I think that's
coming out that's not that's for Kevin
show and looking forward to that
I also loved yesterday's show with
Martin Short one of her favorite people
of Martin Short one of the very rare
people who was super funny when he was
twenty years old and now at the age of
85 Oh still just aging really well yeah
because someone asks you a question
doesn't mean you have to answer - yeah
it's really great that's extremely -
guys a minute 30 left in this 24 hour
stream this is crazy I can't believe I
lied to you but if you highlight this is
the hard way I love it we're with
highlight we're was good that's right
I'm with a good friend and I'm with
Conan this is awesome it's this really
great new way I'm having a great time
especially there's a huge 24 hours of
life that has been lost it's 24 hours of
not knowing why Blaz babbling on and on
yeah I mean I make positive things it
didn't sound that positive it was pretty
it and it resolved it was very pretty
classic that did resolve I think it
super mean no offense I oh you've heard
the song before you've heard this song
before it just rhythmically works really
well that's right sick can you see the
second verse about Moses quickly Moses
is the best guy
Moses is fun even without coffee
Moses looks a lot like a black-haired
King Joffrey you know I'll tell you
something else I have to be very careful
when I play never to play a recognizable
tune because then we have to pay for it
and those things cost a lot of money
they do and I know a lot of songs and I
yeah I'm sorry I can play them pretty
well but when I'm on camera they tell me
Jeff Ross the producers like don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it you can't afford
it so Ken if you want it down this
building you like this show ya know take
the head when you look at what it's like
backstage at our show there's live stuff
wandering around yeah there's just piles
of manure there's sawdust
there's people naked fighting each other
yeah yeah you go to The Ellen Show and I
oh my god everyone's riding around on a
on a you know pop it like a portable
like what are they called live a segue
that's segue and they're all like have
some gold have some gold have a
flat-screen
welcome to Ellen and then you come to
our show and it does look just people
weeping and it looks like yeah when you
first come into our
[Laughter]
[Music]
Marilyn